do you find that mr depp has proven all
the elements of defamation
answer yes
johnny depp is speaking out after a
victorious day in court following his
weeks-long defamation trial against
amber hurd the jury decided his ex-wife
did indeed defame him awarding the actor
15 million dollars in both punitive and
compensatory damages
has mr deb proven by a greater weight of
the evidence
that question the statement was made or
published by ms heard
answer yes
johnny's been spending time in the uk
since closing arguments and he wasn't in
court for the verdict but a friend of
the actor recorded him signing a
statement on wednesday
and that statement the actor shares it
to instagram reflecting on the trial's
origins he writes quote false very
serious and criminal allegations were
levied at me via the media which
triggered an endless barrage of hateful
content although no charges were ever
brought against me it had already
traveled around the world twice within a
nanosecond and it had a seismic impact
on my life and career and six years
later the jury gave me my life back i am
truly humbled mr foreperson is this the
verdict of the jury
all right is it unanimous
johnny goes on to thank his supporters
and those fans they were a constant
presence outside the virginia courthouse
johnny says quote i am and have been
overwhelmed by the outpouring of love
and the colossal support and kindness
from around the world i hope that my
quest to have the truth be told will
have helped others men or women who have
found themselves in my situation and
that those supporting them never give up
he concludes the statement by writing
the best is yet to come and a new
chapter has finally begun truth never
perishes
today's verdict confirms what we have
said from the beginning that the claims
against johnny depp are defamatory and
unsupported by any evidence johnny's
attorneys camille vasquez and benjamin
chu didn't mince their words while
celebrating their court victory we are
grateful so grateful to the jury for
their careful celebration
to the judge and the court staff who
have devoted an enormous amount of time
and resources towards this case the
attorneys who have become celebrities in
their own right amid the high-profile
trial say this was the justice system at
work and we were honored truly honored
to assist mr depp in ensuring that his
case was fairly considered throughout
the trial
we are also most pleased that the trial
has resonated for so many people in the
public who value truth and justice now
that the jury has reached its conclusive
verdict it's time to turn the page and
look to the future thank you all so much
and thanks to the jury it should be
noted amber also received a verdict in
her countersuit against depp the jury
awarded her 2 million dollars in
compensatory damages
question the statement was seen by
someone other than misheard answer yes
following the decision amber shares this
statement summing up her feelings after
the verdict quote the disappointment i
feel today is beyond words i'm
heartbroken that the mountain of
evidence still was not enough to stand
up to the disproportionate power
influence and sway of my ex-husband